>> I DRINK RED WINE FROM A PAPER
COFFEE CUP.
I LOOKED OUT AT THE LIGHTS OF
THE COUNTRY I LOVE SO MUCH AS WE
FLEW HOME.
>> Sean: JOINING US NOW, FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR, FORMER SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE, AND THE CREATOR OF
DEFENDING AMERICA COURSE, ON HIS
WEBSITE, NEWT GINGRICH IS WITH
US.
HOW ARE YOU?
>> I'M DOING WELL.
I HAVE TO SAY, I DON'T THINK
WHEN THIS BOOK CAME OUT AND THE
BOOK TOUR BEGAN, I DIDN'T REALLY
EXPECT THE LEVEL OF SHRINKAGE.
HE'S GOING FROM 6'8", BY THE END
OF THE TOUR, HE WILL BE ABOUT
5'2".
LIBERALS ARE ATTACKING HIM, THE
MEMBERS OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION ARE ATTACKING
HIM, CONSERVATIVES ARE ATTACKING
HIM.
HE'S MANAGED TO HAVE A RANGE OF
PEOPLE DESCRIBED HIM AS
DISHONEST THAT IS REALLY PRETTY
REMARKABLE.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW WHAT MY
FAVORITE WAS?
>> WHAT?
>> Sean: MY FAVORITE WAS, I
THINK HE IS 6-FOOT EIGHT, TRYING
TO HIDE WITH THE BLUE CURTAINS
TO AVOID THE PRESIDENT.
I AM LIKE, REALLY?
YOU GOT TO BE KIDDING ME.
>> [LAUGHS]
YOU KNOW, HE'S A VERY BIG GUY
PHYSICALLY.
I DO THINK PSYCHICALLY, HE'S
BEEN DRINKING WITH EVERY
INTERVIEW.
AND I GOT INTRIGUED TO THIS
MORNING, SO I WENT BACK AND
REREAD ROD ROSENSTEIN'S REPORT
WHICH HE DID TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
JUST BEFORE THE PRESIDENT FIRED
COMEY AND THEN I READ THE
RECENTLY RELEASED
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT ON
ANDREW McCABE.
WHAT IS REALLY SOBERING, WHAT
ALAN DERSHOWITZ WAS SAYING IS SO
IMPORTANT, YOU HAD THE NUMBER
ONE AND NUMBER TWO PEOPLE IN THE
FEDERAL BUREAU OF INVESTIGATION
BOTH ENGAGED IN BEHAVIOR THAT
CLEARLY VIOLATED THE LAW.
I MEAN, I THINK THE WHOLE IDEA
THAT THE TOP TWO PEOPLE AND WHAT
IS OUR PREEMINENT
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IN THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY, LITERALLY YOU OF
HOW TO INTERNAL REPORT BY THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL SAYING ANDREW
McCABE LIED, THIS ANALYSIS BY
ROD ROSENSTEIN, WHICH IF YOU
HAVE NEVER READ ALL OF IT, IS
REALLY STAGGERING IN THE DEGREE
TO WHICH IT REPUDIATES COMEY.
THAT IS WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
GOT.
THESE TWO TAKEN TOGETHER, IT IS
VERY SOBERING TO THINK YOU HAD
THAT DEPTH OF CORRUPTION ON THE
VERY TOP OF THE FBI.
>> Sean: THEN LOOK AT ALL THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE EITHER BEEN
DEMOTED OR FIRED OR PEOPLE WHO
WILL BE FIRED.
I'M SURE AS A RESULT OF THIS.
THEN ULTIMATELY I DO BELIEVE
CRIMINAL ACTION WILL BE TAKEN
PLACE.
I DO WANT TO GO BACK TO THIS
IMPORTANT QUESTION.
WE HAVE A FISA COURT.
I CAN'T IMAGINE JAMES COMEY
SAYING, WELL, IT COULD BE TRUE.
AT THIS LATE DATE, MEANING THE
RUSSIAN BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
DOSSIER.
AT THIS POINT, HE KNEW SHE PAID
FOR IT, THAT WAS THE BASIS, THE
GRASSLEY-GRANDMA       GRAHAM MM
GRASSLEY-GRANDMA       GRAHAM M,
GRASSLEY-GRANDMA       GRAHAM MT
GRASSLEY-GRANDMA       GRAHAM ME
GRASSLEY-GRANDMA       GRAHAM MB
GRASSLEY-GRANDMA       GRAHAM ML
GRASSLEY-GRANDMA       GRAHAM MK
OF THE APPLICATION THAT THEY
USED JUST BY ANNA TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ASSOCIATE.
THAT TO ME IS CRIMINAL.
YOU DON'T LIE TO A JUDGE, NOR DO
YOU WRITE AN EXONERATION BEFORE
YOU EVEN INTERVIEW THE PERSON.
HE DID THAT, TOO.
>> CLEARLY, IF YOU WERE TO GO
THROUGH ALL OF THE FALSEHOODS
WHETHER YOU ARE TALKING TO
CONGRESS OR OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES,
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT COMEY HAS
DONE, CLEARLY THEY ARE A
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF INDICTABLE
GROUNDS.
THE CASE MADE TODAY BY A VERY
SENIOR ATTORNEY IN WASHINGTON
WRITING IN A LEGAL JOURNAL, THAT
IF YOU READ THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL ON ANDREW
McCABE, ANDREW McCABE DID
EXACTLY WHAT GENERAL FLYNN DID
FOR A LOOK AT HOW GENERAL FLYNN
HAS BEEN TREATED AND LOOK WHERE
McCABE IS AT THIS MINUTE.
CLEARLY, IF YOU WERE TO APPLY
THE LAW, AND TO NOT JUST APPLY
THE SOCIAL NORMS AMONG GOOD
FRIENDS, BOTH McCABE AND COMEY I
THINK WOULD BE IN VERY SERIOUS
LEGAL RISK AT THIS STAGE.
>> Sean: THE NEW COMEY
STANDARD, IF WE WILL USE THE
COMEY STANDARD, NUMBER ONE, I
GUESS EVERYBODY IS PART OF A
CRIME FAMILY, WHICH IS
OUTRAGEOUS IN AND OF ITSELF, THE
STANDARD IS, IT MIGHT BE UNLESS
PRESENTED TO A JUDGE, SO THE
JUDGE WILL KNOW WHO PAID FOR IT,
THE JUDGE WON'T KNOW IT'S
UNVERIFIED, AND THE JUDGE WILL
THEN ISSUE A WARRANT TO SPY ON
AN AMERICAN CITIZEN BECAUSE IT
MAY BE POSSIBLE.
IT'S POSSIBLE.
>> WELL, LOOK, THE NUMBER ONE
THING TO RECOGNIZE OUT OF
EVERYTHING WE'VE LEARNED FROM
JAMES COMEY IS THAT THIS IS THE
WORLD ACCORDING TO COMEY, AND
WHICH COMEY IS ALWAYS RIGHT.
SO AT EVERY STAGE, IF SOMEBODY
ELSE DISAGREED, HE IS
DISAPPOINTED IN THEM.
THIS IS A POINT MADE BY
ROSENSTEIN AND HAS MEMO TO THE
PRESIDENT.
COMEY SEEMS INCAPABLE OF
LEARNING FROM HIS MISTAKES.
INCAPABLE OF EVEN THINKING THAT
THERE ARE MISTAKES.
THE LEVEL OF DANGER THAT WE HAD
IN HAVING AN FBI DIRECTOR WHO
HAD THIS LEVEL OF MEGALOMANIA,
AND WHO DECIDED THAT HE WOULD
SUPPLANT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL,
WHETHER YOU LIKE OR DISLIKE
LORETTA LYNCH, SHE WAS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
NO FBI DIRECTOR HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO DECIDE THAT HE WILL
NOW REPLACE HER AND YET, THAT IS
WHAT HE DID, AND IN EXPLAINING
WHY HE HAD TO ANNOUNCE WHAT HE
DID ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON.
HE WAS PROTECTING AN
INSTITUTION.
IT WASN'T HIS JOB TO PROTECT THE
IT IS AN ACT OF STUNNING
ARROGANCE TO BELIEVE THAT HE WAS